[Music]
we're halfway through 2018 now et is
breaking down the best style statements
of the year so far
starting with Margot Robbie while she
may not have won Best Actress at the
Oscars for her role in hi Tanya come on
she was our winner for Best Dressed on
the red carpet slaying in this white
Chanel creation and her fresh platinum
blonde chopped up by the green light I
don't know if it's flattering but I sure
like it and we do too I not had lighter
Kermit the Frog Sarah Paulson was
anything but subtle and Prada at the
ocean's 8 premiere in New York City I
loved it so much it's a plastic grass
skin I love it
kendall Jenner rocked this little black
redemption dress to the Vanity Fair
Oscars party in March and the sexy look
had us saying dramatic sleeves plunging
neckline sheer lace oh my
Saoirse Ronan was effortlessly elegant
in this pink long-sleeved silk gown by
Louie Vuitton at the Screen Actors Guild
Awards in January
making her number 8 on our list then
there was Rihanna who shut it down at
the Met Ball in May sporting this Pope
inspired Maison Margiela look that was
perfectly fit for the events heavenly
bodies themes
I love how playful and Blake Lively was
red-hot at New York Fashion Week on
Valentine's Day I show me a minute in a
timeless Michael Kors patent leather
trench Mike was just so happy he's
always smiling and exuberant and you see
that in his in his designs Bella Hadid
kicked it old-school in this vintage
leopard print dress from Dior to
celebrate her sister Gigi's birthday in
New York in April and we are living for
it
[Music]
then there's Beyonce who brought down
the house at Coachella rocking custom
ball mine and killer Christian Louboutin
fringe boots
[Applause]
Tracee Ellis Ross looked fierce in this
Marc Jacobs gown and matching turban at
the Golden Globes opting to wear black
to support the me to movement and I
really felt like the choice of black was
a beautiful wave that everyone could get
involved in whichever way they felt
comfortable and whichever felt like an
empowered moment which for me was a
turban I'm obsessed with this I saw this
Marc Jacobs turban on the run poo and it
walked down and I was like I will wear
that turban Amal Clooney stunned at the
royal wedding in this chic
mustard-yellow Stella McCartney dress
complete with a side tip matching hat
and her best accessory hubby George
Clooney but the biggest style statement
of them all goes to Megan Merkel who was
a vision on her wedding day in custom
Givenchy and a white Stella McCartney
gown for the reception